[Music]
so i didn't really
i didn't get to watch the debates last
night and i see oh my god dude
yeah oh man you missed something good
yeah i
i i don't know maybe i'll watch it on
stream or something i don't know but
i was a i was just you know i i saw
everyone's tweets and posts about how
dumb everything was whatever there was
gonna be like twitter
sorry go ahead no no no what do you say
he's always gonna be twitter what
i thought there was gonna be a bunch of
twitter highlights from it i didn't see
a single one
yeah yeah it was kind of like we could
probably turn this off because it was so
infuriating to listen to that i was like
we could probably just turn it off and
just see the good parts on twitter
or if there's like comedy highlights or
something like that because it just
like that's how much you're not getting
from it as a
as a citizen you know what i'm saying as
a civilian i'm not a citizen but you
know what i'm saying i'm watching with a
citizen
and i'm like we're just not getting this
is so like unfair to
the voters it's like yeah we don't
they're just bickering they're like
[ __ ]
yeah it was it was so weird it was like
a you know
classic like just pissing match and
they're calling each other names and it
was just
you know reminded me of like trying to
interpret that was like trying to
interpret
you know instructions from your from
your teammate
as the other two in the squatter and the
gulag also trying to to communicate with
each other you know what i'm saying
you're watching that other thing about
is cod you're like man i've been in this
situation
[Laughter]
sir please stop spamming the mic you
stop spamming the mic
calms calms comms com stops where is he
where's he where is he comes comes comes
comes
guys shut up shut up shut up okay
[ __ ] dude doesn't matter right now
this is like like a [ __ ] two on four
right now just shut the [ __ ] up your
teammates are like left he's left he's
back left he's back left and you're like
[ __ ] off
that sort of felt like trying to get any
info any real info from that but anyways
keep going sorry what were we gonna say
no so i just
i was having my chuckle because i was
laughing what if
within the first minute you know the
broadcast begins and they have the music
and they walk out on stage and all that
and then
say tonight we're here with blah blah
blah do that whole thing
you know everyone's like built up to
this moment and then within 30 seconds
of the first
question the two of them just go full
dementia and [ __ ]
their [ __ ] pants let's take
a fat ass dump in their pants
mr president will start with you how do
you feel about like oh
[Applause]
i mean dude that's kind of what happened
like i know but no like
what happened but i mean literally like
if he just [ __ ] his pants and then biden
just thought
he was in the like in a urinal and just
stepped to the side and
pulled his hog out and just started
peeing on the ground and he was like you
can't miss if you're a foot away
[Music]
damn i think that's what honestly i
think that
that's what people like kind of you know
like i feel like
trump keeps calling him you know what is
it sleepy biden and stuff like that i
feel like people kind of
yeah like he paints him as such like and
and conservative twitter just constantly
repost videos of him like [ __ ] up his
they actually the both sides do it right
so i'm pretty sure that's what everyone
expected were they for these two guys to
go up there and just like [ __ ] their
pants
but they were both like i mean like
biden especially like put on a good
showing he definitely like
impressed for sure really yeah
i mean you know the clips i've seen him
like on
you know on like news broadcasting stuff
like fumbling words and just like
forgetting what he's saying and stuff
like that
and then like everyone talking about him
and being in his basement or whatever
the [ __ ] it is you know
i'm like damn is this he gonna get get
up there and just completely embarrass
him
[Laughter]
i'm sad they didn't [ __ ] themselves man
i know man
mr president uh joe would you like to
he's just staring out into the abyss
mr biden is it's your time go ahead and
just [ __ ] yeah
you have two minutes and he just turns
to the side and just walks towards the
side stage
and someone comes out and turns them
back
they put a bus stop on stage just like
that
like those dementia hospitals like
they're like just in case
any either of them tries to leave um
they'll get caught up and think they
have to wait
for the bus is that true yeah man
there's a
there's like a famous one i think it's
in i don't know where it is actually but
yeah they put a bus stop outside the
hospital is like a preventative measure
so
and did it work i assume it works you
know
it's just a fake bus stop
that's some [ __ ] i mean
that'd be really funny to just keep up a
bus stop that doesn't work
and either for dementia people or
patients or dementia people
or just you know it doesn't it's not
part of the buses to me they're like if
you're just a random tourist and you're
like oh i could
probably hop on here it's just one big
milk prank yeah
it's just a live stream actually that
would be really funny that would be like
a good
like art installation
non-functioning bus stop somewhere and
just stream stream it all day
yeah and people who have to work
standing at it being like um
what's the deal bro yeah and rich people
just sit there and watch it
no no it needs to be uh a fake bus stop
for uh
for like uh uh like one of those bar
bicycle things what do they call those
oh bicycle yeah barcicle but it's almost
there
yeah i couldn't put the two together you
just gotta come by
they just they need to prank it so the
barcicles
has ten actors on it and it sits at that
stop and it leaves
and then people go oh like you know and
then
there's a sign on it says every 15
minutes and this [ __ ] just never comes
back
people waiting to get on a bicycle yeah
and p put that [ __ ] in santa monica
like party bicycle pay as you go
you can get off or stay on and
or what if it's a barcicle that never
ends
[Laughter]
like they you hire some host that is
supposed to his only job is to like
maintain energy
and and be a host for like as long as he
can possibly go like
hours hours 10 hours he's still like
blowing the horn and like come on folks
on our left
is the santa monica airport and we're
just like
six hours in people were like i don't
understand we run out of booths
just just take them from [ __ ] santa
monica who got
in south bay just deep
hours away from where they were [ __ ]
up on the 405. all right
on our left is santa barbara
barcicle i know there's i know there's
one person
here loves alcohol it's like that sounds
like a damn good time
yeah until you run out that's what i'm
saying what happens when you you know
hit the last bottle of long branch what
do you do then